this is important right now because he
here this taught a lot it's taught
across colleges it's taught on campus
and it's taught in the media it's taught
in the entertainment industry today
whenever we're talking about the
unspeakable acts committed in the name
of Islam across the world in record
numbers well what is it that we're
inevitably told who say all right don't
ever use that voice again but the
Crusades as a matter of fact it's so
commonly used here's a montage remember
that during the Crusades in the
Inquisition people committed terrible
deeds in the name of Christ why are only
Muslims mentioned in talks about
religious extremism did you all forget
about the KKK Westboro Baptist Church
Crusades the Muslims didn't go up from
Jerusalem and March up to Europe to
attack Christendom no the christians
marched down to jerusalem to attack the
muslims the crusades in the inquisition
he went to the big ones the ones where
it's like everybody agrees why wouldn't
it
well are you probably believe that too
so it is time to get your paper plates
knife and fork ready because we're about
to have a sacred cow cook-off
it's a nice little graphic there they
get us some letters so let's get through
these these myths there's if you've been
taught about the Crusades I'll call them
the second Crusades the retaliatory
Crusades I'll explain in a minute
because it's important that they were
unprovoked that it was just Christians
running across the globe with pointy
hats and swords killing any and all
Muslims they could find innocent or not
simply because they didn't like their
brownness it couldn't be further from
the truth now it's important because
this is taught in schools across the
country a lot of people believe this the
fact is that these Crusades the second
Crusades they were a response to the
first Crusades from Islam from the
Muslim onslaught for hundreds of years
for over 400 years or as consistent
Muslim expansion aggression violence
Muslims took Jerusalem in 638 ad they
pillage Rome and 846 AD Christian Spain
and Portugal and 711 ad sounds like a
gas station but its historical context
that you need to know that's why you
tune in southern Italy during the ninth
century the Ottoman Turks were advancing
into Europe and invading the Byzantine
Empire in I think I think it was 1010 50
1060 something ad that Turks from
marching into Asia Syria and then the
big one the big reason so if you look at
this map and you can see it expanding
was 1453 the capture the sacking of
Constantinople which basically put an
end to the Christian Byzantine Empire
and here's the thing
I understand military expansion okay so
I'm not going to condemn the Islamic
world for doing this back then okay now
right away that should change the
context to the Crusades because people
war and people go back and gain
territory and win but the sheer
brutality from Islam for example they
deliberately desecrated the burial sites
of Peter and Paul in 846 of it exactly
these are military terms you need not
concern yourself with they would behead
people as we see today they had methods
of torture that were incredibly brutal
the dhimmitude meaning they were put
they would force non-muslims to be
subservient and pay taxes and they
didn't get to enjoy the same kind of
rights as Muslim got to to enjoy
something we don't mention amongst our
white guilt millions millions some
people estimate higher than 100 million
died under the Arab slave trade we have
courses that were forced to take here in
the United States to learn about the
evils of slavery that we stopped or are
they teaching those anywhere across the
Islamic world is there is there is LA
McGill
is checking your Islamic privilege a
thing so this kind of brutality this
kind of inhumane treatment and yes
military expansion and cultural
expansion is what led to the retaliatory
Crusades people like Vlad the Impaler
you've probably heard of you know Vlad
the Impaler a common known as Dracula
believed Dracula
it's how fladam Brailler was an actual
person some [ __ ] a little bit of a
sadist I'll give that to you Vlad the
Impaler became really brutal precisely
because it was a prisoner and saw the
inhumane treatment saw the brutality
from the Islamic empire that's why seen
as a folk hero to some now I would say
he went a little too far the other
direction with impaling people and
allegedly drinking blood he found the
line he found the line but good for him
he found it you find it in the Giants
back but they heard the message loud and
clear he was one of the few people who
fought them off he was using Verizon
back then while everyone else was on
Sprint they got the message was a head
they weren't Vlad incur no roaming
charges so all of this is what led to
the Pope putting forward the idea of a
Christian crusade for the first time
that kind of gave license to killing
people who weren't Christians because
they were facing the extinction
potentially what they thought of their
culture of their way of life to who they
saw to be barbarians at that point and
it's important remember that the
Crusades the retaliatory Crusades from
the Christians at that time met the
criteria of the Just War clause they
were thought of as an act of love in
response to Muslim aggression
historically they met the criteria that
was necessary so that's a big myth that
we know another one that we hear a lot
in that context matters is that the
Crusades are some sort of a source of
modern Muslim aggression
angst toward the West there are terms
out there often paired it by booty of
course the young turks reza aslan
you've probably didn't have you learned
this in college where they talked about
when Christians took Jerusalem in 1099 I
should say took back Jerusalem yeah
which is really what they wanted to do
they'll teach you grow when Christians
took Jerusalem in 1099 when they took
back Jerusalem kind of like when people
talk about the war of 67 when Israel
gained territory they don't talk about
how many countries was at Egypt Jordan
I'm gonna remember the third one we're
saying you're teaming up to eviscerate
them and Israel just happen to kick
their asses and took their land for
protection it's it's left out so when
Christians took back in 1099 you've
heard this term right that they're siege
of Jerusalem blood they had blood up to
their knees you might have heard it's a
term from the land a lot even he's so
much of that Bill Clinton said this
after 9/11 mind you the context matters
in trying to be sympathetic and show his
tolerance and how progressive he was to
the terrorists and terrorist supported
across the Islamic world Bill Clinton
had this to say those of us who come
from various European lineages Bill
Clinton yeah I try that are not
blameless indeed in the First Crusade
when the Christian soldiers took
Jerusalem they first buried a synagogue
with 300 Jews and I was gonna say that
yes that's an unnecessarily dark to do
it in a Bill Clinton voice and proceeded
to kill Muslim women Muslim children at
the Temple Mount I want to get down to
the part where you said description of
the event describes soldiers walking on
the Temple Mount a holy place to
Christians with blood running up to
their knees the common term he
reiterated it I can tell you that that
story is still being told today in the
Middle East and we are still paying for
it right after 9/11 first off that's
physically impossible for blood to be up
to your knees of course and they by the
way it may sound like we're trying to
take something literally that they meant
figuratively no no no they will teach
this in college
literally and Bill Clinton meant it
literally Steve widen cough pointed out
this is not only a physically incapable
but corrected the record regarding the
Jerusalem battle standard practice at
the time dictated that a city that
refused to surrender at the site of a
seating army would suffer and in all
consequences of a successful siege this
is why many cities back then agree to
terms before commencement of this siege
it doesn't mean all Muslims did that
they didn't necessarily follow the rules
of war as we've seen now they didn't
really follow any civil rules of
engagement the point is 11th century
warfare was was harsh this shouldn't be
a surprise yes the retaliatory Christian
Crusaders did kill many inhabitants but
the events are not out of the ordinary
and modern accounts like Bill Clinton
when they throw it out there there used
to stir up backlash against the West
they're the ones who are stirring the
backlash up against us here in the
Western world they are the ones who are
encouraging people in the Islamic world
to use it as an excuse because the
Crusades were largely forgotten and they
weren't used as justification for Isis
for Taliban for take your pick for that
rule of the day and here's something I
would like to put forward you know what
not only is it understandable now given
this context that the Crusades occurred
the Crusades were necessary they had to
happen I'm not condoning the loss or the
the taking of innocent life deliberately
but the Crusades as a military and
cultural response needed to happen
because they happen precisely to stop
the kind of barbaric behavior that you
see in the Islamic world today and you
saw up until today in any other place
where the Islamic empires were able to
conquer let's talk about the Armenian
Genocide where where thousands upon
thousands of people were killed brutally
including the crucifixion of young girls
downtown I still don't know how Ana
Kasparian sits next to him let's just
don't talk about it it only gets them
mad in the eighteen hundreds to do
Muslims killed over 4,000 mostly
civilians in the city of she beheading
their king they still behead in the
Islamic world you've seen these
headlines this still occurs all across
the Islamic world I'm not only talking
about Isis but in places like Saudi
Arabia in some of these places in the
islamic world that actually have modern
technology you would consider them here
in the new
world beheadings occur in soccer
stadiums as a warm-up act we get
Beyonce's nipple they get a head rolling
around being kicked for a goal I'm just
saying that the reason the Crusades
occurred were to stop the kind of
behavior that shocked you every single
day when you read the news from the
Islamic world because guess what that
was going to be the entire world even
today Isis and their ilk are still
forcing non-muslims into dhimmitude with
taxes and violations of basic human
rights and here's here's the main point
whenever religious islam has been given
the opportunity to - to congregate given
a petri dish in contrast to the rest of
the modern world to the rest of Western
civilization Europe the United States
the Islamic world when given the
opportunity to civilize when given more
time doesn't get better
doesn't make progress it almost always
gets worse it gets worse and that's what
was happening before the Crusades
because of the Islamic Crusades and that
would have occurred across the entire
world it's not one of those that you
left us like to act sometimes they'll
use this argument right that's well
Christians have come a long way if you
go back to the Crusades
they were pretty uncivil and some
members of Islam are just enough it's
like that phase for them or they need to
get beyond it no Christians before the
Crusades did become much more civilized
were advancing into the new world then
because of Islamic onslaught and
behavior they had to get down the dirt
the Crusades occurred and they continued
to make progress by contrast anywhere in
the Islamic world where what they
expanded into with their Crusades has
been allowed to continue it has gotten
worse and darker and if you're
progressive and you feel the need to
appease it
this video subscribe by clicking the
button that says subscribe if you're not
aware of it now there's no way you're
learning the Internet at this point I'm
not going to help you but this was
clipped for my daily show available
exclusively to lotto with credit calm /
mug club members of your student
military or veteran entering that promo
code it's less than six dollars a month
and you get daily content no more clips
Plus this hand etched mug oh I just when
I feel it I got a chill like on the
inside